e não é à toa que o tempo é orixá Então
deixa ele agir na sua vida preta
é o tempo da água correr da ferida
estancar do Machado reger da dor cessar
e deixar o tempo guiar sua vida preta o
tempo do raio iluminar do peito Abrir do
caminho Abrir do peito florir deixa o
tempo mover a sua vida preta
e o tempo das coisas e as coisas no seu
tempo tem a tempo para entender o tempo
das coisas
e para
é amar a noite pele que tiveste olhar os
medos nos olhos desbravar a floresta da
tua alma
me respeita preta
a respeito tempo e deixa ele passar
é porque não é à toa que o tempo é orixá
o amor jubal Orixá iroko
o teu colar é de concha seu vestido se
arrasta na areia ela tem cheiro de mar
ela sabe cantar ponto de sereia nós
empinando pipa na praia era futuro
inevitável então inexplicavelmente lindo
como nascer de covinhas em bochechas
pretas olhos que se cruzam dedos que se
entrelaçam nossos sobrinhos gritando tia
o tia o menino grande cortou Nossa pipa
o nosso encontro foi um respiro em meio
ao caos tão real quanto desgoverno da
época prova irrefutável de que afeta
tipo Alecrim que transcende a presença
física quando terminar ser
e eu confesso eu chorei duvidando existe
a leveza de hoje mas eu sonhei com os
nossos sorrisos sujos de sorvete numa
praia com areia de chão batida
e com pessoas pretas pele cor da noite
que chamamos
em família
oi oi Janaína quando eu tô feliz eu
choro
bom obrigada tá